good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday and
good morning jackie
good morning claudia happy thursday that
feels like a tuesday
wow acknowledge this space it's so rare
to not only get a short week but a
three-day one for
us at that it's just such a beautiful
time you know
even though it's raining here in new
york whatever on the way down from the
weekend it's just important to
acknowledge these spaces
i just feel like we had a three-day
weekend but most people had a four-day
work week
this week and i think that what we're
learning
is that this is how life was meant to be
lived and i think it's like you still
get so much done in a four-day work week
arguably more are you really more i mean
we dropped a redheads episode this
morning that
was so good we recorded last night about
the book american dutchess truckers for
the redheads are coming out the sirens
are blaring because
we had such a great conversation about
the book i think all of us liked the
book
even more after talking about it we were
sharing like all of the interesting
historical factoids that we learned from
the book so even if you didn't read the
book i think you could listen to the
episode
but if you're struggling to get through
the book i saw some comments in the
redheads facebook group
keep going just keep going i know it can
lull
but you want to get to the end and then
i think once you see the big picture
you'll really like it do you think
you're only saying that because the book
was your selection
like i would say that about if i chose
the book but if someone else was like
i'm like no i'm not finishing this
no because the other girls all said like
they would never have read a book like
this but they're so glad that they did
okay and if they had picked it up and
been like oh no like that
you know ten percent be like this is not
for me but they had to finish it and i
think because when you
when you do finish it you have such an
appreciation for the story for the woman
and then you listen to the episode and
it was such a fun one so the redheads
it's never too late to join
and i would argue you should join on
this book if you love downton abbey if
you love bridger tin
this is the book for you i think there's
no better time to become a redhead than
at the tail end of a four-day work week
i think that's like a famous proverb
yeah and especially like as we're
heading into summer you need a bee tree
i don't know what you like to read on
the beach but
there's something for everyone out there
at the redheads there's something for
everyone rebecca just announced her new
book choice
and it looks really good has an amazing
rating on goodreads so
we're just chugging along here at the
redheads chugging along checking along
i'm chugging along as well even though i
almost got taken out last night by a
migraine
i went to the nick game which is so fun
i haven't been in so long
but i really forgot that like literally
every time i've ever been to a nick game
i get a migraine it's like a migraine
minefield it's like because of the noise
bright lights
strobe lights so much noise and like
because it was a playoff game like it
was so loud
i left with the worst [ __ ]
migraine of my life but it was worth it
because first of all
me and ben made it on tv and not even
msg local we made it on
tnt nba on tnt and we were looking
we were looking okay second um i had
amazing chicken fingers like
chicken fingers at madison square garden
just hit different they're so good
and three like ben was so happy that i
finally agreed to go to a game with him
so like we all won except for the knicks
they obviously lost and put themselves
out of the
conference yeah um but a good time was
had by all there were
so many celebrities at the game like
literally have never seen they always do
like celebrity row
yeah and it's like always tracy morgan
marishka hargitay and like one other
person
but tracy morgan was there marisha
hargite and peter herman were there
and also last night was the series
finale of younger
oh wow so don't spoil it if you've seen
it but i'm gonna go home and watch it i
watched last week's episode yesterday
so i'm so behind it's honestly usually
when a show i like ends i get really sad
but after watching the season it's
certainly time to get
time to go yeah and did you tell peter
that when you saw him no but like
honestly i kept thinking i was kind of
like ish close to him i'm like if i run
into him i'm
definitely going to be like i don't know
if you remember me but like you were on
my podcast and we fell in love
yeah maybe i wouldn't say that in front
of marishka though yeah so
he would remember chris rock was there
okay so many like
jets former baseball players the people
were going nuts i had no idea who they
were
they didn't put her on the screen but
emily radakowski was there okay um
michael j fox obviously and it's
actually
well nevermind i'm taking back what i
said and some other guy from the
sopranos who i didn't know but i think
his name was michael and everyone like
went wild it was just i was thinking
like do other basketball teams have this
many celebrities at their games like no
well it has to be in a star-filled city
so i'm sure in la
yeah atlanta yeah yeah like a milwaukee
bucks game like there's no celebs
there might be one or two maybe some
locals maybe they're playing a team
maybe someone's in town
yeah it just depends but new york is a
star-filled town it was like
because we live here because we live
here yeah it was like a celebrity row
presented by douglas element like
every single time out i'm like there's
another celebrity like it was crazy it
was so fun
that's so fun i'm so glad that you went
yeah no it was a good time a good time
was had by most
except for obviously like the people
playing for the knicks very sad for them
shocking that this team i know i'm no
basketball analyst but shocking this
team even made the playoffs
like no offense like what were they
doing
and now that i know all about it like
justice for julius randle
so cute by the way like kind of loved
him um
like people were upset with him because
he's like the star player but like it's
a team sport like
he can't do everything he had nine
turnovers okay he also was the only one
who made like any points like and that's
literally the only thing that matters is
how you win a game
so it was just like frustrating i don't
understand how this band of yellow belly
losers made the playoffs because they
were so bad like it was like
embarrassing
to like be a part of this franchise be
wearing a jersey
well imagine how your husband feels oh
my god and i was trying to like give him
you know some will to live because ben
has been an expand for so long they
haven't made the playoffs in eight years
and of course they weren't gonna make it
past this round
like trae young and
bogdanovic like they were so good like
they literally couldn't miss
and so i'm like ben we were never making
it out of this round like a lie but you
should just be grateful that one you've
got experience
the memories the memories and ben is the
only person i know there were five
playoff games three of them were in new
york and then went to every single one
of them so like you got to experience
wins you got to experience losses like
that's just a part of life and honestly
that's just a part of being a nix player
i'm a knicks fan so like just
be grateful yeah no it seemed like it
was a fun time for the fans and like
be glad with what you got yeah be happy
with what you got and it was literally
like a jewish
the one i wanted a high school reunion
like literally every jewish person i'd
ever met
was at the next game it's literally like
it should be sponsored by
yeshiva university like it was literally
like
jew central nice yeah well that's really
fun glad that you did that
yeah i mean it was annoying because i
got home late and then i talked to
beverly hills but it was worth it
because it was such a good opportunity
it was such a good episode i had
such a busy hectic day yesterday because
of all my reading that i had to catch up
on and then doing the outline for the
episode and recording with the girls but
it was it all turned out so great
and your work pays off i honestly like
miss the book like
oh you know you know the feeling of
course so redhead did you talk about it
did i dream about it i did the night
before when i was in the middle of the
book
um but the new episode is out now when
we're done here head over there check it
out
you know poke around on the redheads see
what books are out there like
you're probably thinking no i don't read
like it's not for me but like why don't
you read
that is a great question one in which i
used to ask very frequently
you could read like just try it
yeah even though i'm on like a downward
spiral now like started like four books
in a row that i just hate
me too we were liars sucks it happens
sometimes it's
part of the journey so annoying you'll
find a book that hits we're gonna read
malibu rising next yeah for redheads
just like you and i are gonna read it
and so um i think that's to be great me
too that's our girl taylor jenkins read
i'm thinking of like taking like a
relaxing weekend i say that now but i
really just like don't want to be
hungover
i hear you my friend i know so i think i
need it like for my soul
no it's so nice i know that you're not
gonna stick to it no but it's nice that
you
that that's what you want well i am
hosting shabbat dinner at my house so i
really can't do anything friday night so
i'm 50 of the way there unless i get
drunk a shabbat but never know anything
can happen
don't count out you're countess you're
meant to get drunk at shabbat
i'm just like meant to get drunk period
you know where's the weirdest place
you've ever been drunk
i don't know me neither i didn't have an
answer i just was like wondering if you
had one
i hadn't i haven't thought about it long
enough i'm sure there's a weird answer
yeah i think like ben's been drunk at a
funeral which is like so disrespectful
it depends if it's like it depends on
the culture
that's true sometimes it's immensely it
wasn't a celebration of life it was like
a full-blown mural
like a tragic accident you know yeah
yeah okay
cool that's my husband okay well i think
we should get into everything because we
have a lot to discuss so without further
ado
where are you it's raining today so he
did not come into work must be nice for
him he's seeing a mental health day like
the rain is just like kind of gets to
him the rain in spain that flies
mainly mainly though not completely
mainly
without further ado here are the fast
side stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's episode should come as a
surprise to nobody because it is brought
to you by
bruce the most fabulous electric
toothbrush on the market and they've
come out with fabulous new seasonal
colors these ones are so trendy i saw
you about which color did you get i got
this
mauve and i got this package from bruce
yesterday that
turned my whole day really i got a whole
new brush in a new color
and you have a whole new like gina
sequoia i have a whole new lease on life
it literally was the most exciting
package i've opened in so long
you guys treat yourself to the gift of
opening up
your bruce it's so amazing and so this
morning i bruised with my fresh
brush and last night too and look at me
you got the mauve cloud but they have
new colors green dream
a gray mist so i've had the millennial
pink one for a while
it might be time to switch up my
aesthetic i didn't even know that that's
what i was craving
and now this mob just walked into my
life well for those who don't know
the bruce is the best electric
toothbrush on the market in our opinion
and it also is the most affordable
because a lot of them can cost over 200
which actually is insane like come on
bruce has you covered they've got
everything
that you need the charging stand it
comes with six unique modes to customize
the brushing experience and it has a two
minute timer
for a complete even clean in all four
quadrants of your mouth so you don't
sometimes i'm brushing my teeth i'm like
have i've been rushing for 35 minutes or
35 seconds but the brush times it for
you
also the battery life lasts four weeks
it comes with a magnetic charging stand
and a compact travel case
they also offer a subscription program
so you never forget to change your brush
head again
just because you're using electric
toothbrush you still need to change out
that brush head it will become filled
with bacteria but
you have to remember it because the
subscription service just sends it right
to you and you just swap it out
whenever the time is up and you don't
need to keep track of it innovation
man the design is super sleek the
electric toothbrush from bruce has a
modern aesthetically pleasing design and
it comes in trend driven
seasonal colors and it looks great on
your bathroom counter these new colors
are only available for a limited time
though so get them before they're just a
distant dream
and get 15 off your brush toothbrush kit
because you know we got you covered and
the refill plan
when you use promo code toastedbruce.com
that's 15
off using promo code toast.brush.com
love it treat yourself to a bruce the
vibes are so immaculate you think like
oh why am i getting so excited about a
toothbrush
you'll see you'll see sign on brush your
teeth
bruise your teeth trust us on this one
okay first story big news david spade
will be guest hosting bathroom paradise
amid chris harrison's break from the
franchise says thesaurus
spade will be one of the celebrities in
a rotating roster of guest hosts for the
seventh season of the abc dating show a
source confirms to people
rep representatives for abc and warner
brothers did not immediately respond to
people's requests for comment
so let's discuss david spade in general
and then also um
a rotating what is this jeopardy right
and just the fact that like
chris harrison's return is being
postponed even more yeah i and i don't
know how he comes back the
the lord gets postponed the weirder it
is when he comes back
yeah and so i feel like david spade is
great he's super funny
um the thing is though with the hosting
and i feel like we talk about this a lot
like when you're a talk show host or
when you host a show and why chris
harrison was so successful at it
is because chris harrison is literally
like a big nothing burger he's like
boring he doesn't do or say anything
funny
and that's the point of the job you
carry the show along it's not about you
it's about the contestants and i feel
like david spade is so funny so famous
that like
you can't help but make it about you
because you're just that kind of star
and
comedians always want to like you know
crack a joke when honestly
it's not the point of the job so we'll
see how it turns out but i think like
having celebrities come in is actually
not a great idea because yeah
that's just not the point of the role
yeah i just feel like one on the one
hand if you would ask me who's going to
be the next host and it's not going to
be chris harrison i would have said
wells
yes so that feels like a weird decision
and then they could have bumped up
another cast member they're like
literally
promoting from within so many bachelor
contestants that go on to be hosts so
like there are a lot of people who could
have
auditioned for this job within the
community because i do think having a
celebrity like takes away from like the
bubble of bachelor life but i also think
the show is floundering
and they're so desperate and they're
like okay we don't need to protect the
integrity of this bachelor bubble
we need viewers right and so i think
they saw this as an opportunity
obviously to like make people
what are people talking about right now
like the chris harrison of it all which
is like this big scandal that does not
make chris
or the franchise look very good so
they're just trying to like deflect big
celebrity
i get it i agree with you i think this
is like a not a good sign
because the bachelor has always been
loved by celebrities but always
protected the integrity of the community
of bachelor nation and while this will
be probably fun and funny
it's just different and i feel like it's
not a good sign
yeah but bachelor in paradise is a very
funny silly show
so it's true it's not like it's david
spade hosting the bachelor yeah
so we shall see it's just weird like i'm
i'm not as weird but i do
i did plan on watching bachelor in
paradise because it is better but and
that's
and then that's it for me no
bachelorette
oh definitely not watching katie's
season katie season comes first
like is premiering soon so we get it's
premiering next week like we get a break
we get a break but i will be watching
bachelor and paradise but if you're
looking for katie season
commentary someone to make fun of it
endlessly the snatcher will be returning
to toast news network
she's back for the new season and it'll
be dropping every week nobody likes a
roast
quite like the snatch she literally
posted on her instagram today like not
looking forward to the bachelor
premiering next week but so excited to
get the snatcher back just so i can see
nicole and we can make fun of katie
oh my god yeah like you can't wait to
listen it's gonna be harsh season over
at the snatcher
oh we love harsh season we do um and
then also the second part of this whole
conversation is like
let's discuss the fact that chris
harrison is not returning like yeah
ever question mark yet again i don't
know i don't know how he returns after
this he doesn't even want to like
but what is he gonna what is he gonna do
for work i don't think he like needs to
work
jealous yeah i wonder if he'll still
have an executive producer credit on the
show
for sure i think he'll he's still
probably making money and will continue
to make money
off of the show yeah i don't know
like what his finances are but i feel
like he's totally fine
remember when he wrote a book like a
fictional book yeah like nicholas sparks
yeah um i'm sure he's fine but like
for the rest of his life i don't know
it's so
i mean he went from having like the most
ideal job
in the country like very little work
not year round universally loved
and adored by literally every human
being
he went from that to literally being
like the most divisive
character in all of pop culture like an
extremely unemployed
unemployable yeah 100 yeah 100
so we've been there chris it it gets
better
and if you want to start a podcast news
network news network is always higher
we go by our alternative name cnn
cancelled news network
um we will we would literally love to
have you because if you're canceled
then you're for tnn then you are for tnn
okay you ready for our next story little
wine news
wine news yes bethenny frankel is
launching forever young
wine after her skinny girl success yes i
saw this like tick tock where she
announced it
and i feel like bethany's had a lot of
success but none of it has been on
tick-tock
and um whoever she hired for big shot i
won't spoil it it's not helping her with
the tick tock
and she either needs to have a complete
360 because it's ruining her brand or
just get rid of it completely
like on big shot they could barely wrap
their heads
around inside photo shoot instagram and
twitter yeah they didn't even
introduce tick tock into the mix it's
clear they need to
bring doing the tick tock no no i
believe that she is that's literally
what i'm saying because they're like
all from her house in the hamptons and
i'm sure it's just like her brain in the
house i don't think her assistant is
like staying with her
and bryn is recording the content okay
well her latest spirit follows the
success of her skinny girl branded
products she said can lightening
in a bottle strike twice i cracked the
code in the sparrows business once
before my little cocktail baby was the
fastest growing liquor brand in history
at the time i paved the way for many
other media personalities to launch
their own cocktail brands and created a
new category
now she's launching forever wine as
superb next level and elevated
saying that with every sip you will
understand why i entered back into this
space
she definitely created a new category
like i don't think you can really
speak about skinny girl without giving
kudos to that
and it's true like lightning did strike
and i i just don't
see it striking twice well she for every
young wine is currently available in
malbec cabernet sauvignon and sauvignon
blanc with the rose coming soon
and i think if i ever see it i'm going
to try it yeah of course can you tell me
about
what makes a company special or it's
just like a wine company it's just a
wine company
and i think that it's like she's saying
it's really good wine
i don't know i feel like now the space
is very crowded
it's crowded i don't know it's interest
it's an interesting play
yeah and it's interesting to see like of
course skinny girl was successful for a
multitude of reasons it was a great idea
was low calorie it had great marketing
but the show was so integral in the
success you can't deny that
and now she's not on tv yeah so i wonder
what that means for the success of this
new company right but she
oh she has the built-in platform so
i think i i'll be i'll be surprised just
like i was surprised when you said that
skinny girl shapewear is their
biggest that was shocking vertical i
would never have guessed that
so i think anthony has like business
things happening that we don't see
yeah same but i do think that
still to this day like her biggest hit
was the skinny girl
cocktail yeah because it sold right
so we'll see but um very interesting
very interesting okay next story
meghan markle and prince harry's top
baby girl name prediction has a hidden
historical meaning
so people are predicting what megan and
harry's baby girl's name is going to be
so i wanted to get your thoughts and
i'll share my own about what we think
the name is going to be
most people are saying they think the
name will be philippa
as a tribute to prince philip and
philippa is like a a royal
name i don't think that's going to be it
i don't think it's i see why people
would think that i don't think that's
gonna be it
i would like to know what you think it's
gonna be well let me just say
megan and harry are yes royals but now
they're really like hollywood
celebrities and no offense like philip
is just like not gonna cut it
in the hollywood school districts oh
it's also pippa middleton's name
oh oh pip was cute pippa is cute but i
also
i don't know if that would stop them
because i don't know if it needs to stop
them
i i think megan has too much pride as
like her own woman
to have a name shared with kate who we
know that she doesn't like
sister yeah i just also think i just
don't think
me neither yeah it's not going to cut it
and like in um
even though schools no the school
district
in calabasas is not like you have with
moses you have north and philippa
no it's just not going to work it's not
rolling up the town also archie and
philippa
does not work not at all archie and
spencer
you think it's going to be spencer of
course after lady dai
i got that vibe after the oprah
interview i do believe i said it on the
podcast first so like just in case i'm
right i just want to credit
um because one it's super meaningful to
lady die
of course and we know that harry and
megan are very
of course you know connected to her
legacy
and i also think it's like a good
hollywood name it's like kind of like
gender bending it's like spencer could
be a girl or a boy
i think it's good i think it's good i
think it's good i have three
you wrote them down i wrote them down i
have three that i think it could be the
first one
is margo i think like named after
princess margaret but they're obviously
not gonna name her margaret so i think
margot
is a a fresh take on on that royal name
i mean margo's an
absolutely stunning name i've never met
amara who like i wasn't intimidated by i
think it's it's
modern i think it could be i like that
um then i added just a classic royal
name that
is just classic which would be alexandra
and they can they can rip off of that
too basic for a hollywood a-list couple
living in calabasas but archie and
alexandra
very so cute very so cute and very royal
yeah and then the third which is another
royal name
not as big in like britain but just a
pretty name that has royal ties
sophia lovely as well but again not
going to cut it
on the marymount high school play i
think it will
i think margot and sophia will and i
think alexandra if they
with a with a nice nickname i think it
will cut it those are my choices
yeah no no i i think they're all really
good choices obviously not as good as
spencer because that's like so clearly
the answer here you know
or phillipa no it's gonna be now
and who are these people uh who came up
with this prediction just like people on
twitter are like actual experts
um i don't know people magazine
oh so it's just like people from twitter
yeah i guess so or maybe it's like the
odds
the in the betting world yeah i mean i
think i don't a lot of people aren't
even bringing up but i think spencer's
like
so when you were gonna say like people
have come to a conclusion like what the
name's gonna be it's like obviously
spencer no but like
prince philip just died this is the
first child being named
first child being born after his death
like philippa
yeah you know people yeah people in the
uk need to be a little bit more creative
because like philip like is a boy's name
and i think they're just like trying to
make it a girl's name and you know like
when you're speaking spanish you just
change like the o to an a like
like it's just not a name filipina no
that's like a country yeah um you could
make it like philly phyllis
gorgeous phyllis at marymount high
school phyllis markle
mountbatten windsor phyllis windsor
actually has mountbatten okay they're
not gonna call her phyllis map out in
windsor
present in school like yes they will
it's gonna be
philly windsor yesterday
very stunning or no oh i was thinking
maybe also
may but she'll be born not in may so
may is ugly too but maybe may is a
historic
real name yeah queen mary's name was may
may of tech
got it it's funny when we talk about
names because like we have you know
so many listeners and again we're
offending people yeah like we have
toasters named may so i'm like maze ugly
justice for the mate
i take that back it's actually quite a
lovely name did you even say it was ugly
because i
i don't think that it is i do believe i
said that yeah oh okay well i disagree
and also uh i i'm sorry but i don't take
back what i said to the philippa
toasters
[Laughter]
even though i'm like almost certain you
don't exist if you do exist like
come on the shop come on the show and
tell us what it was like growing up with
the name like philippa but
pippa like so cute there's just so many
nicknames like if you have a great
nickname it doesn't even matter
and that's really what it's been like
for the royal family like they all are
named the same thing yeah like their
fathers and their grandfathers and they
all have these nicknames like albert
bertie right there's one queen victoria
had seven kids
and the last one they just called it
baby love that my uber driver today had
seven children and four of them were
named claudia
oh yeah four of them yes four he said i
got in the car and he was like cloudy
i'm like yeah
he's like oh it's my daughter's name and
he's like i have four i'm like oh my god
i'm one of four also he's like no i have
seven kids but four of them are named
claudia i'm like stunning like
i've never heard of that interesting
take on them on a modern name
yeah um also what i was just about to
say what were you talking about named
james i think the name elizabeth is like
really pretty but i think it's like the
best name for nicknames like there's
literally so many betty
betty liz lizzy lisa lisa
beth beth there's so many yeah and it's
it's so it's been around for so long
that you don't have to worry that it's
going to go out of style
timeless we never go out of style we
never go out of style
um and i guess like someone could be
named victoria or a take on
victoria because they don't have that in
the family right now i thought that's
what you were going to suggest as well
but the thing is i just don't think that
megan and carrie have enough reverence
for queen victoria no it's
not not even queen victoria i just think
that like it's been made clear like
they've
annexed themselves from the family like
they don't want to be royals so i don't
think this royal name
lineage they give a [ __ ] right even
though archie was born when they were
still royal so they had to abide by the
rules
i agree but that's why i think they're
going to choose a name with a loose
royal tie-in
that is modern and pretty on its own
that they like regardless
like with spencer unlike philippa oh
yeah
it's too obvious like i'm going margo or
sophia
okay those are both stunning names
stunning archie and sophia
love to see it sophia with an f by the
way
that was a good joke um okay by the way
speaking of stunning things
today's episode is brought to you by
hair food they offer simple superfood
inspired products that will make your
hair look
and feel amazing whatever hair texture
or hair type you have
hair food has a recipe for you in
addition to their beloved
nourishing coconut milk and chai spice
collection you've got to try some of
their new recipes
like the apple cider apple cider vinegar
herons
which is perfect for days when your hair
needs a gentle cleanse before
conditioning
the turmeric and turmeric turmeric
turmeric and almond oil detangling milk
which takes care of the most stubborn
knots and reduces frizz and the shea
butter and pear color repair concentrate
which makes over-processed hair look
vibrant and healthy they all smell so
good in every hair product
a hair food product is free of sulfates
parabens dyes mineral oils and
they are certified peta cruelty free
so it's so nice when you like hear
good things about certain like
everyone's always like you have to use
apple cider vinegar in your hair and i'm
like what then there's literally a
product
for you also the turmeric and almond oil
detangling milk is so fabulous because
detanglers are not just for children
so if you're looking for nourished
healthy hair it's got to be hair food
look for it at amazon walmart and target
that's
hair food at amazon walmart and target
love it i love hair food wait before we
get into the next story have you seen
the
the commercials for the show why women
kill no
it's on paramount plus and it's from the
creator of desperate housewives mark
cherry
uh oh they no i think it's probably like
a lesser known creator oh so it was an
assistant on
for sure but it looks like something we
would like so oh yes i agree
just want to flag that for you um it
sounds like a show that already had come
out it's not new is it
no it's new it hasn't come out yet it's
well it's now streaming on paramount
plus
not an ad just wanted to plug that for
you i just think i saw i've seen the
commercial twice and it's like mad men
vibes okay oh you know what i started
last night
the um halston series on
netflix yeah i started watching the
wrong one everyone's like watch holstein
i'm like hey so i go to
apple tv and the first thing that comes
up is this boring ass documentary on
amazon prime but then i actually did
have like a good foundation of knowledge
about like who holstein was and like the
whole thing
um it's pretty good actually it's uh
who's who plays he's like a famous actor
who plays halston
and he's like very you know uh talented
actor he's just liking it
being such an actor in the you know what
you and mcgregor yeah yeah yeah
he was in beauty and the beast right
yeah i think he was uh
the clock no no no no that was um
a different mcgregor i believe okay
um the show is really good um and it's
definitely like an interesting story
worth telling
but some of the acting is community
theater like
it's really shocking because it's like
you're right he was in beauty and the
beast he was right who was he the glock
he was hold on go back to what you were
saying i'll find out i was just saying
like some of the acting in this hallson
series is very community theater-esque
especially coming from you in
who's like a world-renowned actor i mean
lumiere
thank you he was amazing he was amazing
so yeah
exactly flying through the air with the
greatest of ease
and i'm just like this is the same guy
as lumiere like his acting is just like
not his best and i know that's
might be crazy to say seeing as how i'm
a brain dead [ __ ] but still
like i just think he could have done
better okay but it's a great the fashion
is like so
the second thing you think i should
watch it you will love it like it's
elegance it's like 60s 70s new york what
happened to
elegance like that's literally what it
is like it's just
fabulous like they really i actually was
happy to have saw the documentary first
because they got a lot of the people who
are being portrayed in this hallson
series
and they look exactly like like i knew
who half of these people were just
because i saw them in the documentary
like the real person
interesting yeah it's good people really
liked it and recommended it to me
and i'm only on like episode three but
it's really good in the girl who plays
liza minnelli like who knew that liza
minnelli was
integral to the success of halston you
know who would have known that
um she the girl who plays liza is great
it's really good okay cool next up a
little sports news that's so crazy that
we promised to update you on
churchill downs bans the kentucky derby
winner medina spirits trainer
for two years after the horse fails two
drug tests wow
bob baffert had convinced me but
apparently this horse is on drugs
you know when you like when you are
accused of something and you defend
yourself like so
hard and you're willing to do anything
take a drug test dna test it's like
of course you're innocent but like to go
through all that
just to be a liar yep the bob baffert
the hall of fame trainer of medina
spirit the winner of this year's
kentucky derby has been banned by horse
racing venue
churchill downs for the next two years
after his prized horse failed two drug
tests
results of results of the derby winners
tests were confirmed to new york times
and cnbc on wednesday
the horse had two positive drug samples
of banned steroid drug
betta methisone from the day of the
derby in may
so what happens to the title does it go
to someone else
i don't know i don't know
and honestly being banned for two years
it's kind of like a slap on the wrists
because like once you you know
what is the word i'm looking for t
tamper
with the integrity of the race you
obviously have no respect for horse
culture yeah therefore i think you
should receive a punishment slightly
harsher
than a two-year suspension yes i would
just say i do think this man has respect
for horse culture because he's like
dedicated his entire life to it
i don't know i don't know if i would why
is this the horse on drugs
right like justice for the whole like
there's so many things to unpack here
but i think what's not even being said
is like the unethicality
of giving a horse drugs when the horse
can't consent to wanting drugs you know
no like it's mean the horse is probably
like minding his own business and all of
a sudden he's like
working so hard and then he's feeling
like speedy and having anxiety and it's
like he didn't ask for that
no he didn't that's like somebody
unknowingly like roofing you
that's it's unethical i actually feel
really bad for the horse i feel bad for
the horse because he felt like such a
winner and now he feels like a loser
not even that he was given drugs that he
did not
ask for therefore yes the suspension
should be more than two years it should
be five
oh interesting so the it has yet to be
determined if this
the if medina spirits win will be
rescinded from the jockey who rode him
right john velasquez the victory marked
his fourth derby win that jockey
the horse's owner zidane would have to
forfeit the 1.8 million dollar first
place check if the horse is disqualified
you know in another world so it's
unclear yet if he's been disqualified
from winning the derby but the trainer
has been suspended for two years got it
i mean
in another lifetime like you and i could
have and should have been horse
jockeys like our proportions are just so
perfect for it
we actually did grow up riding horses
like that could have been our path
that could have been our path our jockey
is too big and our horse is too small
what's that from secretariat is there
a are there a lot of female jockeys i
think it's from seabiscuit because i
don't recall secretariat being deficient
in any way
same thing like oh for sure check with
the movie secretariat and the movie
seabiscuit
are literally the same movie about one
named horses that start with s
with us that were champions though i do
think that seabiscuit
was like oscar worthy no no
i think the opposite no no no see it was
toby mcguire i'm sorry seabiscuit the
horse
was a perfect specimen of horse yeah
perfect specimen and secretariat
right all right he was like a little bit
of an underdog and like toby maguire was
like a little taller
i'm talking about the movies seabiscuit
like was in
theaters it was i think it got nominated
for a bunch of oscars i don't think so
secretariat was like a d
com no no yeah yeah yeah secretary was a
decon a disney channel original movie
like it was
we we love that movie it's like our
family's favorite movie we think it's
like god's gift to this earth
when it's literally like a disney
channel commercial free movie
no no you guys if you've never seen
secretariat treat yourself
and it's so good it's not decon like no
it's unbelievable and there's so much to
unpack
diane lane is that her name and aj
michalka who also has a singing
performance uh-huh and the grandma from
hannah montana movie
yes yeah there's a lot so good there's a
lot there
and medina spirit is there going to make
a movie about him yeah will it be
oscar-worthy or will it be a d-com
we'll have to wait and see and it's
going to be a really sad one yeah like
he was on drugs yeah okay are you ready
for our fifth and final
i would like the medina spirit film to
be told from the perspective of medina
himself
and what it was like to be just poked
and prodded when literally
nobody asks for it yeah and i agree
i agree are you ready for our fifth and
final story sure it's a final
story
[Music]
dude okay
and this is going to lead us into our
beverly hills recap but erica jane and
tom gerardi's legal scandals
are at the center of a new documentary
that was fast
this may not be the biopic erica jane
was hoping for the star of real
housewives of beverly hills and her
estranged husband tom gerardi's legal
scandals
are the subject of a new documentary
called the housewife and the hustler
abc news originals film centers around
how many
around the singer and her lawyer ex and
the implosion of their carefully
maintained image
the filmmakers were able to obtain
voicemail messages court records
and a never-before-aired deposition tape
of gerardi according to abc news
yeah also um heather mcdonald is in it i
know i saw that
i'm really shocked that this turned
around so fast because first of all like
there's yet to be charges dropped like
yeah it's story's still being told so
this is a little premature in my opinion
yeah but i'm still gonna watch it yeah
when i first was watching the trailer i
was like oh my god is this an episode of
american greed and then i was like oh no
it's the housewife and the hustler which
also sounds like a rom-com
100 the beauty and the baker like it's
literally literally the beauty in the
maker
um but i guess it will end with like you
know tom has now been in
right like with a little text on screen
yeah it's a little premature for sure
um and the name is super bizarre
but when i saw it i thought this was
like a fan edit i'm like this is like
the name is so tacky and i'm like this
is obviously like
somebody some housewife fan like made
this video but then it turns out it's
like fully gonna be on hulu
yeah on june 14th and so it's gonna be
really interesting to have this
information like
about the the facts of the case while
watching it play out on beverly hills
but you know somebody did chime in
somebody who i did not expect to uh hear
from
on this matter but leah black from the
real houses of miami whose husband
is like one of the biggest lawyers he's
like a tom girardi
yeah what was his famous case something
about jfk uh
hold on i'll tell you it was a famous
one roy black
roy black because i want to find oh here
this is what she said about the
erica girardi of it all she said i hope
people keep an open mind about
erica hashtag rhob the law partners
slash accountants didn't know the
california bar didn't know
the creditors didn't know the city
lavishing husband with awards didn't
know
so why would people assume a singer
dancer with no background in law and
finance should know
be nice okay so leah black has spoken
and honestly i respect her opinion
he's known for his for his gaining an
acquittal in 1991 of william kennedy
smith on charges of rape
oh that's the case from that he met
his wife at is it like because he met
she served on the jury
what right leah black served on the jury
of a case that he of the big one gotta
get on a jury
oh my god that's crazy that's what i
remember
they are so rich yeah and they've been
married forever
wow i bet she was happy she got served
that day yeah i mean i can't find it now
but that's what i remember but correct
me if i'm wrong that's so interesting
the housewife and the hustler june 14th
hulu i'll be watching 100 yeah it's like
research
love that heather mcdonald was in it i
know she's a perfect person for him she
is
like she is a commentator on the subject
and that actually makes me think like
this is gonna be a well-done documentary
because they had the foresight to put
heather mcdonald she's so funny and she
really knows everything
yeah she's like been she's been watching
calabasas like
um well that is a great segue into our
real housewives of beverly hills recap
which is brought to you by
solawave um it's
we started using their advanced skin
care wand a few weeks ago and we can't
imagine our life without it we've
noticed a huge difference
in the texture brightness and radiance
of our skin and what we love about the
solar wave wand is that it combines four
different skin care
technologies including red light therapy
and micro current
which are backed by decades of science
so you know it's not a gimmick
you can rest assured that you are using
what you're using on your face has been
tried tested and approved by tens of
thousands of happy customers
ourselves included this wand i've heard
about red light technology and i know a
lot of celebrities use it
but this wand is perfect it's the
perfect size
and it comes with this amazing serum
that i've been using
for other skincare needs like when i use
my gouache it's a great hyaluronic based
um skin serum and the wand just makes
you feel glowy and tight and bright
it's super lightweight and portable so
you can throw it in your purse or carry
on with you when you travel it feels
amazing on our skin like a luxurious
facial massage that leaves us with an
instant glow so if you want to get your
skin summer ready use our special coat
at checkout to get 30
off for a limited time they also offer a
30 day risk free trial and free
expedited shipping
just go to my solarwave that's
m-y-s-o-l-a-w-a-v-e
dot com and enter the promo code toast
for thirty dollars off it is a
fabulous skincare tool for the summer
it's also great for travel
real results and check out that serum
with hyaluronic acid it's fabulous i
highly recommend
amazing i just do want to confirm she
met her husband when she was doing jury
duty during the rape trial of william
kennedy smith
and roy was his lawyer a year later leah
ran into him and they started to date
now they've been married since 1994. so
i guess they met
a year later not nobody like happened if
they had it's like when it's a mystery
when you see someone on hinge and then
you like meet them in real life like so
do you say you and zach man on hinge
i say we met at work just like they met
at the trial no
you're no no because you and zach match
sean hinge and like never message and
then a year later like you met
like two months later whatever so you
say that you met
at work at work when you met in person
listen and then go with the one that
sounds
better yeah of course the jury's a
better story but they say they ran into
each other a year later sounds like
they just so happen to have been in the
same room no one's but if they hadn't
been on that jury she probably would
have been like hey i was on the jury and
i'm sure the jury became famous so they
probably recognized each other from the
trial
he probably saw her in the box he was
working but he was like ooh that
beautiful lady and then a year later she
shows up honestly
speaks to his skills as a lawyer that he
was able to fall in love with a jury
and get the acquittal and also get the
acquittal like that's why he's one of
the highest paid lawyers in the country
and they live in the biggest house of
all time that literally has never been
cleaned a hundred percent
okay real housewives of beverly hills
part two in tahoe
the scene opens this was really like the
downfall of sunstrack like that's what
the episode should have been called she
was being
so chaotic and saying some of the
dumbest [ __ ] ever so
sensitive to so sensitive about the
stupid prank which wasn't even funny
and honestly she just like kept kind of
perpetuating and trying to like compare
like her struggles as a white woman to
the struggles of crystal as an asian
woman and garcelle's black woman when
like
honestly like they couldn't be more
different and crystal
i'm i like crystal a lot and i fully
understand her frustration like not even
being able to give
sutton the time of day like sutton is so
fragile and so sensitive and like
literally crystal was i understand that
like
there was this joke going around and
sutton didn't know so there was like
some confusion like
that made her cry for some reason but
once she
once she was in on the joke and everyone
explained to her chris i was like i was
kicking you because i didn't want kathy
like she couldn't let it go yeah she
kept like digging herself into this hole
and she couldn't get
out of her own way and she really should
have left and went to her room because
she needed just like to
remove herself from the situation but
like sitting there and trying to get
over
like to process all of her emotions in
front of everyone it was just getting
worse and worse
and so yeah she wasn't helping herself
whatsoever but i think it's clear for
the women who have known sutton for more
than one season now that like
she is an odd bird and so many of the
women who
didn't really understand her season one
just like i think crystal is
experiencing now
now know her really like her and
consider her a friend with all of her
quirks and everything that's very true
like our cell was being very protective
understanding and i think even like
remember i feel like last season erica
and dorit had like no time for something
yeah now like there's just more
understanding of her because sometimes
people take a minute to figure out
and so i think crystal's experienced
what everybody is experienced last
season with sutton it's just like what's
wrong with this woman but i think
crystal has a lower threshold for
sutton's [ __ ]
yeah definitely but i just think that
like when you come into this group like
sutton is just like the obvious weak
link
because everybody else is like so like
sure of themselves and fabulous and this
and that and like sun is just like
oh bizarre she's just bizarre yeah so
i can understand why they're not meshing
whatsoever right now and i think
sutton didn't absolutely nothing to help
her case but now things are going to get
weird with this next like scene into
next week
i was like literally my heart was
beating fast like when
crystal who was still miked and on the
phone with her friend i guess when
you're new to a show like you always
forget that you're miked she didn't even
say anything so but that conversation
wouldn't have been
aired if sutton didn't go downstairs
because my son got drunk
because why was she going down to her
room to bring her her coat in the middle
of the night like
yeah oh i guess well maybe they should
say she left the room like 20 minutes
before and she left her quote upstairs
they said 45 minutes later oh
hey okay that make that tracks so she
might have just been like trying to like
be helpful and extend an olive branch
you know when like you got your trunk
and you just want to help everyone yeah
it was just like a weird thing it was
just really weird and then especially
considering next week we find
out that like crystal was naked and she
was just complaining on the phone how
like she thinks sutton is so weird and
like
and crazy and creepy and then she walks
in and she's naked so no
it's weird it's a weird dynamic one
which i don't think we've ever seen
and last week we were saying how like we
really feel like we don't get to know
like kathy hilton at all and i feel like
this episode was like
a decent amount of kathy hilton time and
like i don't know i kind of lived for
like she just literally did not go on
that torturous trip that took like an
hour to get to an hour to get back and
the women were like
beat when they were done and she just
like slept till 12. she drank a red bull
because she thought it was a soft drink
like she was being funny so i feel like
i still don't know a lot about her but
she brings like a levity and like a fun
like the prank was her idea
she brings like a good vibe and i
actually think kyle's like very relaxed
around her
yeah yeah not like she was with kim
because i always felt like she i feel
like she felt like she had to protect
yeah it's like kathy is a
grown woman and she knows how like
and kathy can hold her own and like
socialize without the help of kyle but i
think kyle likes having her cool older
sister there makes
kyle feel cool yeah definitely um i just
like
really really and she wasn't even in
this episode but with the previews for
next week when they like get into the
denise stuff again
and lisa arena just says again like no i
was so wrong let's move on
you know like you literally ruined
someone's life like can we take a breath
and like let's discuss it like the way
you always want to own it lisa like
other
but here's the thing like she is owning
it but it's like okay so now what's
the repercussions repercussion what
about denise justice for denise like
you you can't she just like thinks she
is owning it you're right but like
there's
no it's like it's so weird it's such a
weird feeling to like for
to have someone be so wrong and damaging
to someone else's life and then also
like take full
responsibility but like there's no
emotion
yeah it's just it's a weird tactic yeah
no it's
brilliant because nobody can say you're
i know i need garcelle to um
bring going no to bring denise into the
foal because lisa rena needs to say this
all to denise right so it's so easy
that's what it is it's so easy for lisa
to like completely own it say she was
wrong
she was the leader of this whole
movement with all the girls winter niece
is not around
say to denise yes bring denise back on
the show
bring back denise i'm not over it no
justice for [ __ ] denise
yeah um but other than that what really
happened that was it was like a good
episode but nothing
major yeah i thought that like the prank
was just like a little stupid and i can
imagine
like obviously sutton was just so
sensitive and handled everything so
wrong but like if everybody is at a
texting
texting in on a joke and they all
decided to tell the next person the next
person like nobody told her
i would feel like a loser too yeah and
then when they were sitting down
afterwards in the living room i'm like
wow
everyone was involved in the joke except
for her and kyle and i guess like kyle
just doesn't care but like
you're right like she's so insecure and
like she's so not sure of herself so
like everyone's texting everyone's in on
something you think it's about you
yeah and also they just had this like
heavy conversation
about being southern and race and all
these things so like
she probably was already like feeling
like she said the wrong thing right and
now everyone's texting and it's
like it feels like it's about her 100
but then she
just emotionally handled it like
irrationally no the walk from the
sprinter vans
to the living room was so chaotic like
everyone like hovering over each other
it was just so messy um and
and it appears as things don't get
better with crystal because we have that
iconic scene like
what am i jealous of your leather pants
like things don't get better between
crystal and sutton which is frustrating
because i
i do like them both i actually don't
think like some people are meant to be
friends you know like
they're just so different i don't know i
think i could see them being friends
next season i think they just i think
sutton's a really difficult person to
understand
yes but she has won over so like there's
so many people
when last season she was like like put
the mouse down yeah yeah yeah
literally um but i really like crystal i
have to say like i think
she's really like adapting very well
very quickly making friends with a lot
of the girls and i really really like
her like
i think she brings great energy to the
show she brings a whole new level of
like
rich hollywood film industry which i
love
and i think she's really holding her own
very well me i totally agree yeah
great great stuff so far ladies and good
episode tonight is keeping up with the
kardashians
so we'll recap that tomorrow for
friday's episode oh my god you guys
tomorrow's friday just acknowledge it
you know just acknowledge this favorite
let's take a moment to quietly
acknowledge the space somewhere the
moment of silence for friday
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennium morning
show where we deliver the best life
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so it's spotify itunes
stitch or public radio ihot radio cast
box all the places
so wherever you listen to podcasts find
us morning toast leave a five star
review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are we hope you
guys have an amazing day and we'll see
you tomorrow for
friday friday gotta get down
on friday goodbye